all right and we are live the last word
lord cognito ibontas and the amazing
thai guy travis how are we doing at the
campfire let's start with the legendary
cheetah himself he pontiffs i was gonna
let travis go first just to see what
he's up to all right let's get travis
going on let's see how traffic's doing
all right that's the tie guy
he wants to headline i have to be the
opener
there we go save you oh i see what he's
doing okay i see what he doing
it's strategic
i'm doing good man it's been a really
busy week for video games where whether
it's uh the destiny reset stuff that
happened
i'm reviewing a game right now just got
a the uh date the world war z uh preview
out the door um
and uh yeah uh the playstation showcase
today which was
ridiculous i'm still sort of reeling
from it i can't believe uh we're gonna
get another kotor remake i just i saw
the i saw the the leaks and the rumors
but i i've been seeing leaks since i was
like a freshman in high school so i just
i just assumed that it wasn't real and
it is um which is crazy um how about you
[ __ ] yeah bro i mean the same boat as
you i'm reeling i just finished the live
stream with iop
you know we're reeling off the the ps5
you know some some mixed opinions but
mostly consensus it was a great show and
um it was a great show yeah you could
have who's saying no
you you would who's on the team
which member of the realm would you
think yeah the only one like green blood
king likes it but kate will always give
his backhanded compliment in any way he
can but look all jokes aside like i i
loved it i thought they had something
for everyone you know we will talk about
uh kotor like you said um for me
personally you know jess wolverine
man like that is a huge deal for me
unexpected also didn't expect to see
spider-man 2 already looking phenomenal
phenom
all my favorite stuff so to me it's the
the equivalent is even if you didn't
like the beginning or you had any issues
the way they ended was in vintage
you know sony fashion
yup just one more
the feels the emotion they know how to
present to their face so that's why i
just alluded to them on that and uh got
a shout out to home team real quick um
shout out to uh last day of media this
weekend phenomenal trip absolutely
phenomenal love gotta have my my secret
symbol showing on for little support
i saw pictures everywhere everybody
excited to meet you um it looks like
everybody had a really really good time
and sounds like you are
like just deep in that community they've
they've adopted you into the last hand
family man you are you are one it seems
like
thank you brother it was a celebrity now
i signed autographs for the first time
could you believe it wow
me and maddie had a a joke like we're
like yo have we decided and we're like
yo we're out of ink and then we both
looked at each other have we ever said
that before have you have you ever had
that said hey we're out of it exciting
i'm out of the ink can i get some more
also i need some caviar right here to go
with my champagne thanks
yeah it was a beautiful shout out to
last time beat everybody at ign i think
i just signed people's death threats
that's really yeah
i get wow
i'm done with you
everybody
and the thing i will say a lot of people
said because of you cog i'm in the
destiny and i said you know what we got
this cool podcast it's called the last
word we got two great co-hosts you got a
chess man that i was plugging in
everywhere shameless plus nice e i've
been sending people your way you notice
bro they they they're in they're like yo
witch queen i haven't played it so long
i said i got the podcast and the content
creators for you let's go
so now let's go ahead
uh it's been a day actually for me so
some of you guys know some of you may
not some you may have no idea who the
hell i am but uh like in real life i've
been teaching fitness kickboxing for up
over four years now probably closer to
five
uh and today was my last class
so
that one actually kind of hit me harder
than i thought it would
um some of like the actual members and
stuff like got me a card and like that
one actually i was like guys like i had
to get them out the door i was just like
i don't know just hit me in the feels
like i've been doing it for a while and
that's just it's it is a business about
relationships of like getting to know
those people working out with them
seeing them change seeing some one of
the girls there like she's like lost you
know lots of weight totally changed
happier with who she is and everything
like that and just over the past week
i've been saying bye to a lot of people
and this was like my last like
i literally took a picture i was like i
hung my gloves up on the bag it it hit
kind of hard so
my morning was full of like an emotional
roller coaster of all of that stuff and
then kind of got some lunch got a nap in
and then
as you said
then the hype happened so it's like as
it's been a roller coaster of a day
matrix trailer that dropped this morning
watched that a couple times already
which is
i'm all for it like i know that universe
is absolutely crazy
i don't know where they're gonna go but
kiana's in it that's all i need to know
so i'm there
um and then playstation like
uh
like most of it just the end of it blew
me away i mean for sure playstation
studios i was 100 percent there for it
ghostwire tokyo i honestly am almost
less on that one now because the ones
yeah me too i'm like looking at it i'm
like i don't know what this is now and
before it looked a lot more likely of
the space suit with the girl standing in
the street now it's this
weird like kinetic thing i wasn't
honestly sure what to think of that one
um
but yeah the playstation studios i mean
crushed it for me
gran turismo 7 is gonna have to prove it
to me though because i played gran
turismo when i was younger on ps2 and
then as soon as like it was like four's
a three
is probably the one when i was like this
feels better in pretty much most ways
and driving like the driving line was
cool but it was always like the impact
of the cars for me never felt like i was
described gran turismo when the cars hit
each other it's like empty bathtubs
bumping into each other i always just
felt
weird
yeah they didn't have that weight
right that's a great analogy i was like
and it was it's weird but it kind of
worked so it's like grand tournament 7
has to prove it to me both driving games
are going to be gorgeous there's no
question like forza 5 gran turismo 7.
they're going to be pretty wherever you
play them on if you got a nice monitor
but yeah then you said like marvel i was
like what's the then you saw the hat and
i was like i couldn't tell if the hat in
the back was i couldn't tell if it was
going to be gambit
if it was like more that southern
louisiana because it sounded like that
music and then i saw the bloody like the
fist i was like oh this is wolverine it
was like this and it's just marvel's
wolverine i was like i lost my mind my
wife was like she was like what the hell
was that i heard you from across the
house like i like like me yeah i yelled
pretty damn
and then i love it you get to see
spider-man
miles in the same game so how that story
is going to be told and then
venom like just in just picturesque look
like and then the somebody was saying
the talking to the background right
might be craven or something i don't
know
uh and then
it is craven craven the mighty hunter
which i'm actually more excited for than
venom because venom is super overdone in
spider-man
cravings gonna be serious
so yeah that and then you get to see
like oh how much god of war do you think
we're gonna go to baby 30 second trailer
and then we get the logo no it was like
a lot of god of war so i'm on board for
insomniac can really do no wrong they
have to like try and burn me but they're
on
absolute fire god of war
those three alone i'm just like kind of
on cloud nine to look forward to have a
playstation and then like four spoken
like that one from square looks really
really cool if you go back and watch it
like 4k instead of like the stream it
looks really good i'm very curious it
looks amazing
it looks amazing i was like the worlds
look big the movement is like very fast
and speedy it's like secure on steroids
so i mean overall yeah i was like i'm
just on a roller coaster of a day
because like the emotions coming into
today for like my last classes that hit
hard this morning and then this
afternoon with the hype and now i
finally get to like
unwind with you guys and chat and
everybody in here so it's like it's it's
a nice way to
get to the end of the day because it's
uh it's been one hell of a day so far so
yeah and before before we move on i
definitely want to i don't want to share
quote what you said because i know
you know obviously since i've known you
you know you've been doing kickboxing
and and always doing the fitness thing
and obviously the running joke because
you know us doing the
you know the little you know you get the
sit-ups and the things
so that's all part of your culture so i
understand i've been through transitions
and jobs and stuff like that and what
she's not to bring stuff down but i want
to give you roses in that in the sense
that
it's always
mentally tough in the moment because the
finality of it you're like man wow this
is the last day right but just don't
like your future is bright you're super
talented you've got a ton of things
going on and i'm proud to do this
podcast with you you've always been a
stand-up guy and you're gonna be fine
you're gonna ain't nothing i worry about
with you you know
it's it really it happened kind of fast
um things came about in the situation
where it's like
i mean you guys don't know where it's at
obviously but i mean when six out of
eight instructors quit at the exact same
time
and then the other one's right behind
that and then there's basically one
that's probably questionable to stay
very long like that's an entire staff
and
what sucks for me is i've i've seen that
happen like the managers were kind of
first and
all of it was kind of basically in sync
almost but i've i've trained multiple
managers because it helped me have the
split but i've trained four
managers like into that role and i was
like i'm not gonna train a fifth now
complete staff so it was like
it's not a unfortunately it's like it i
had like i was going through like the
emotion like the emotional like the five
stages of like first denial then you've
got other stuff and it was anger because
i'm like mad at the owner for ruining
all this stuff so it's like combination
of a lot of stuff um but yeah i was like
i i appreciate the words thank you bro
absolutely you know i mean you we we
share in similar timelines so to speak
as far as career and journey you know
and i when you said it it resonated with
me because i knew what i was going to i
went through a layoff with it because of
covet and i'm like yo what am i going to
do and then i had to assess everything
and then the transitions and full time
and other opportunities and stuff like
that so just know you know i didn't want
to show code because the other day it is
important that something that you've
known for a long time but you're super
talented the future is bright there's
tons of opportunity you also do an
amazing uh youtube channel sir that uh a
lot of people go to you for uh advice
and hey don't show someone don't show
some of that
those soul souls totally okay it's like
i got i got work to do but but yeah
shout out to all the love lately by the
way past 60k in the past like week you
guys have been insane on the recent
season
[Music]
uh
sir
your event you're very advanced lately
very advanced
but look man future's right man you got
you got stuff cooking just just know
that just always know that
well thank you i appreciate that we
touched more on like i was actually
going to spend some more time on the
playstation showcase and just kind of
that is there anything more specifics
that you guys want to get into on that
like any big standouts that we didn't
mention
what happened to my ps 5.2 that was
going to come out the 8k system that was
going to come up oh that's going to be
like
2 years down the road and stuff like
that
i heard i heard that i saw that rumor
that it's like in the works and of
course like both systems i see have
something in the works like updated
series that's my next year series x
could be the year after that along with
the you know ps 5.2
um
i can see those and it's well just gonna
say and as the chips and like the next
graphics cards depending on what power
and what they can get into them
depending on whereas like as new red
says like the price changes potentially
if they get bigger or lower where they
find all these positions the consoles
are going to be interesting in the next
years because if we have mid generations
that are even more powerful and then you
start moving around some of these other
ones that are already out there like the
series sp and
250 bucks or like there's going to be
some interesting price points but the
way the hardware is going right now like
ddr5 is going to be a big release the
next platform for both intel and amd uh
and then of the graphics cards that are
potentially coming with the
rdna3 and then also the nvidia graphics
cards on the other side with like
lovelace with that technology those are
supposed to be
almost like twice the performance of
what we just got and that was already
pretty massive so the leaps are going to
be big and depending on what they choose
to use for architecture going forward
they could be substantially large now do
i think we're gonna get in k-60 i really
wish people would shut up with that for
either anything like
no but 4k 60 solid with all the you know
bells and whistles and ray tracing
running that is what i would like to see
because nobody's gonna have an 8k tv for
years 4k is getting a lot more
reasonable like i haven't priced when
i'm like
damn these are not terrible anymore and
it's like you know 4k oled 65-inch i'm
like yeah that's that's i mean it's not
cheap but it's also like it's not eight
thousand dollars or whatever like it
used to be so it's a lot more reasonable
but now
no it's definitely like
there's a lot of in the next three years
or so like yeah 2023 2024 tech is gonna
be
yeah very different place i think
yeah it's good it's gonna be good and i
i think what your point is i do it's a
travis joke you know i definitely i
don't pay
the playstation insider community
anybody one thing i've realized is
they're always wrong so so even you know
a lot of people that you watching shows
no one was talking about a wolverine
game nobody was talking about this stuff
that came out so i don't pay that don't
mind but to ease point i do think that
as far as the um the tech stuff i do
think we're in the age now of the
mid-generation refresh i think last
generation was kind of the test bed to
see how it goes you know they i think it
proved that gamers will spend the money
if they want an upgraded experience
where it kind of mirrors pc in some
level right as far as obviously pc will
always be the superior technology always
be ahead of the game the value of like a
even if like a ps 5.2 is like six or
seven hundred dollars what that
potentially is going to do
is the like way crazier value than a pc
yeah you have the custom upgrades and
stuff like that with pcs but the value
of a playstation or an xbox oh yeah xbox
series x2 or ps 5.2 whatever you call
those weird ass things
yeah like the value of whatever you
don't have to spend
10 hours a week uh beating your head
against your pc to try to get it to
yeah correctly
the value proposition combined with what
travis is saying the ease of entry the
ease of use the onboarding we you know
some people still want the convenience
and the ease of use of a box and i agree
and yeah no trust me i i'm always going
to because my thing was just like i
needed them to get the cpus together
because the cpus was not it on console
and thus he lured me over to you know he
lured me over and i saw it and once i
saw that 60 and that envy and me and i
okay you know what i'm saying this is
what i'm here for now i got that okay
now we could have a conversation console
now i could come back if we could have a
nice conversation
i'm just going but that's all i want to
say but i agree with both of you both
you guys make good points on the price
points and the value proposition with a
console
yeah it's like it's it's exciting it's a
great show
yeah overall the biggest thing i saw i
thought i saw it from xbox from corey
barrow rock i saw it from everybody just
like
i love video games
i think that was like the common trend i
saw on twitter and it's true it's just
i'm seeing all that stuff and
whatever your genre of entertainment is
that's fine but man video games it is an
amazing time to be a gamer
more than ever just seeing like what
could uh you know
halo comes out this fall and hits like
crazy then you get spider-man and you're
gonna have like horizon then you're
gonna have star field and then you're
gonna have wolverine i'm like these are
all gonna be amazing like there's so
much potential now in the world of
gaming in the next few years like i
don't know how it's all gonna go down
but there could be some amazing stuff in
our future yeah next year's gonna be
don't forget
destiny
skipped over destiny let's get it i mean
we live in that game but of course
so do we
not get because they haven't added it to
vr but if i have my way
your your favorite game would be
half-life alex paired with destiny
it wouldn't work but yeah that would be
sweet
it wouldn't work at all
well speaking of destiny no we're not
gonna
yes please no i was just gonna say
speaking of destiny we got another week
of season of the lost
um
i know honestly travis for you like you
have really been enjoying the shattered
realm so we got a new one of those so i
want to throw it to you first to see
how you enjoy in this week's um
this week's one apparently you got some
audio sync by the way
i do again boy i love that again
i was like he seems fine
yeah
this week was
good
uh we saw the i what i assume will be
the final of the areas um and we don't
you know i forgot we don't have all of
the powers yet because we still can't
break those uh immune rocks so i think
we gotta wait to get the exotic so my
guess is we'll get the exotic next week
seems right um
maybe maybe
we'll see but anyway we're gonna be back
at uh the first the first world uh next
week so i'm excited for that now that we
have almost all the abilities but yeah
i'm really still enjoying the
metroidvania i did all of my exploration
uh this week and uh the story didn't
move as much this week but
what what you did see was pretty
interesting with the uh
the crow and um
what's her face
pirate lady pirate petra
pet petra the pirate she got one eye
uh yeah
she uh
uh yeah i i i liked that sort of thing i
think probably
crow is the reason that uh that this is
all gonna fall i think uh this is all
not gonna go our way okay uh because
they've been alluding to that a lot like
pretty much all the seasons leading up
to this has been like sabbath and
grooming crow we know that crow has a
terrible history with uh decision-making
ability uh and is also incredibly
susceptible to being controlled by other
worldly forces
etc etc etc and and now he seems very um
very determined to get in front of
sabathun which i think might lead to the
great disaster that we have coming you
also can still hear crow humming uh hum
and savathun's song uh today when i or
this week when i went over to talk to
him i heard it and i was just like damn
dude this is not gonna go well so uh
yeah i'm i'm really liking the uh the
metroidvania stuff the story is uh
probably coming slower than i want but
it's there and
i have to say
i really don't mind the time gating
stuff at this point i'm kind of
i'm kind of i'm kind of enjoying the
fact that there's a limit to how much i
can play because then i have to stop and
i can go
game reviews or other stuff i'm working
on you know i could play other games and
it means that i don't have to compete
with my friends to get the farthest in
the story before they all spoil it for
me and just like you know
uh
do a huge grind for 30 hours all in one
week just to just to finish all the the
story stuff um so i'm kind of liking
that to be honest
i guess i'll miss it when the witchcraft
i was about to say do you think the
witch queen is going to be back to that
like
big chunk of story go through all the
missions kind of experience this thing
and then we'll still have some seasoned
stuff go but yeah it is kind of weird to
think because we've had this like
literally a drip feed year with regards
to the weekly mission the weekly updates
for about 10 weeks and then witch queen
is going to be like
like here's everything it's just like
so much coming at you it's like whoa
i i think uh destiny always has some
drip feed elements and i think witch
queen will too because there's always
some stuff that comes out like a week or
two weeks after like the raid will drop
and then they'll you know come out with
something else and so i think witch
queen will have that element to it but
yeah there's definitely going to be like
a put your head down and grind phase for
witch queen which i'm not opposed to i'm
more just like at this point where it's
so busy and we're about to have a fall
where we're super busy i'm kind of glad
that
they're taking their time with it
because it's working with my schedule
and it's making me hate destiny less
because now i don't have to do astral
projections 30 times in one week i can
do them three times a week and then you
know get the or was the astral line yeah
projection something else
yeah astral projection is
what what i do in my sleep uh
yeah
yeah i know that sounds uh i'm excited
for it but i'm i have to say like people
are mad about the time getting it's kind
of growing on me to be honest
interesting interesting god are you
interested yeah it's a bit of fun
i was just gonna say how's it going
yeah i've been playing a lot i've been
playing the last two days i'm playing
really a lot um you know i look forward
to the story stuff immediately i b-line
whenever the time great release is open
and i'm like all right what are we doing
so you know i'm messing around there and
uh yeah i was very surprised to see that
interaction you know between
petra and the way she was you know very
harsh to crow like yo you're not getting
next to it you're you've been
manipulated you know you can't be
trusted i always find it interesting and
shout out to um jesse's that
they mara doesn't she acknowledges that
he's a guardian but it's a very weird
dynamic that like the unspoken thing in
the room is you are aldrin fam no right
so it's just like it's very interesting
the way everyone is talking to him and
he's he's aware in the sense that yo you
know i'm not the same person or you know
hey this is for me but why i did feel
him on this part he's like
why am i being judged so harshly yeah
when all you dudes got tricked by osiris
too
right and that part i kind of felt him
because he was like bro it was so well
written again narrative team and they're
bad so i felt his plight but i also felt
petra like look when petra pulls you to
the side it was like look i know you
think i'm being harsh but dude got
compromised
yeah that part is true right so it's a
it's a good conflicting thing now i will
say i think what is hilarious travis is
that
i find it this is well writing when like
after you do your astro whatever you do
your shadow thing and we what is it
called officially the shattered what is
it called shadow drum
is it called the shadow right wrong
shadow and then there's different names
like this week is wrath of ruins ruins
of wrath rapture
shadow realm
trav you got me you sold me like at
first i was like he over hyping it but
then when i play it it's really fun i
like unlocking the little um things the
um the eye the true sight and then you
go on your little patch you do your
little dungeon stuff okay there's the
pad thing i gotta open the barrier hurry
up rush get in there get some secrets
get some chests and again e you know how
we feel about anything ascendant plane
the mystery the the smog the darkness
you know saying now the little jumping
platforms where you your power your
jumping is taken away
it's really good right now i will find
funnies after you do all this and the
boss fight was real fun it's fun doing
all this stuff solo i have to admit i
love doing it solo now the fun thing is
when you get back you do all that and
then it's like
you have a message from savithoon who
wants to see her friend the guardian i
don't like her calling me her friend i
don't like that
yeah like you the guardian like her
friend and then you know she tries to
sit there and talk about how she's you
know doing all these things and i can
relate to crow she's very
very manipulative very beneficial
literally what she is
yeah like she
she's interested so i want to see where
the hell this is going clearly
we are not getting osiris back i don't
care what nobody's saying all this all
you got to do and then i'll release him
to you look my theory i'm going to say
it now before it happens my theory is
he ain't come back
i think the whole now that i look at it
in a vacuum i was like why was satan 14
running trials right
i think they're gonna do some heroic
irony where it was osiris that built the
sundial to get the his lover back you
know who was dead right
i think this is coming full circle
osiris is going to die he ain't coming
back
and i think trials i mean charles saint
is going to do everything hello high
water to try to get him back to try to
do something to savathun right but i
just think i didn't watch marlin's video
i know eric jk but i got to watch it
please tell me because i didn't watch it
anybody watch my live video
no okay anybody watch it gk tell me
what's going cause i people have been uh
referring to me i didn't get a chance to
catch up with all my lore guys somebody
was saying i think like they think he is
dead
or somewhere i may have kind of blipped
or something like that they're like
because it said he used his body as like
and it kind of
let his i don't know i remember reading
it i don't know the wording at all but
it sounded like
it sounded like he's definitely like
kind of toast
yeah the vibe i'm getting is like
a tolling vibe like your consciousness
may exist somewhere
but your physical body
is done all this we gonna do this and
he's gonna be returned to us nah fam and
as sad as it is for me
it then it will be fitting for the lore
of trials
saint carry on his legacy the trials of
osiris it does kind of fit if he doesn't
come back so my theory is he ain't
coming back after reading that bowl what
is it the wolf bay what what i told you
about that i got it um
but wolf wolf tone draw read the lore on
that you know
i i just don't see it so it's going to
be interesting how that plays out but
again narrative team has been fun i've
been chasing roles i i love i've been
starting my lost sector grind trying to
get those nothing manacles i got some
great loadouts lydia i finally got my
particle what is it reconnaissance
deconstruction that thing is just busted
good it is just yeah it's so good shout
out to my man um i got a shout out to
homie travis you already know dj oros
david james orros the homie he met we
met at the uh last damn media event and
then after i was like bro you owe me my
own vex catalyst i'm holding you do that
and we got it done so i got my vex
catalyst bro that gun did y'all see
daddo's video y'all
bro it's disgusting yeah like
it's so
busted that 1k of voices is just you're
gonna melt everything all
season for so you got six months
fusion raffles are gonna probably get
like nerfed when we go into wish queen
but you got six months to enjoy him for
now bro it is so fun how
busted that god is it is just ridiculous
every aspect of it the extra damage now
the lydia fusion mode and then you just
shoot people four times yeah
he's like every other gun has a
qualifier or an extra step to do the bop
he's like with vex you just shoot the
gun
[Laughter]
it's truly it was a great video i got a
shot there's no build up there's no
certain requirements get charged with
light just pull the trigger
the effects is glorious but no i'm
absolutely loving this season i'm just
right now i'm farming got shout out to
all the homie cactus i'm farming my
cartesian whatever coordinates yes i
need that i need that high dps and
that's it but what about you yeah i've
been having a lot of fun with the season
um yeah so i mean shattered realm of
course shout out to chat helped me put
my video together because i went to go
see shang qi on tuesday actually i had a
private screening so actually got some
friends
to see it so
nice right now movie theaters
i got like 10 people to go enough people
that i knew was like 20 bucks a person
i'm like i can do private theater for 20
bucks a person
i did it too for fast and furious nine
it's a pretty good experience nice so
yeah it's invited both of you but nobody
can
sorry we're halfway across the country
and then all the way across the country
but we'll work on that
um shout out to teddy who did make the
trip
um
but yeah i was like so jump in first you
got the atlas skus which we know that
vex or the exotic quest should be coming
at some point right so i mean if there's
four or five i think there's four of the
little
pedestals where you get like the
backstory
um
and i'm guessing there's a portal that
may once you open the four that we're
gonna go through the portal and kind of
go check out whatever the exotic quest
is going to be so that's the
stasis
trace rifle that's what's i'm going to
say trace rifle and linear fusion rifle
is the wrong thing
uh and then that's the thing that's
going to potentially unlock the walls in
the shattered realm because those are
immune and they kind of like
you know they're bedazzled for now but
you shoot them and they're immune in
certain places so you can see like the
shiny walls i'm like okay something's
gonna happen with those so we're gonna
like
i don't know when we're gonna get the
unlocks and then there's a legend
version of both astral alignment there's
a legend version of shattered realms
we've got more difficulty stuff coming
um
but yeah it's just like it is weird i
will say when you go look for the
anchors on patrol because i've been
doing those videos as well yeah they tie
them very very specifically to landing
zones only and the first day was edz and
you're like well yeah there's a ton of
laning zones go around but it was just
the landing zones there wasn't one
uh west of winding cove whatever that
place where that
all the cabal are out there's not a
landing zone over there and there were
none over there same thing
last week it was tangled shore two
landing zones the one main one and the
one up top you got like two other areas
nothing there and this time i'm like the
only because it's hive and i was like
okay so if we go to the moon you have
sorrows harbor and you have sanctuary
i'm like they're really gonna put them
in sanctuaries like but it connects to
some no they literally put five in
sanctuary and then like seven up top in
um sorrows harbor i was like i wonder
why because if they were
even for like the moon if you start in
sanctuary and then you drive either
direction they could totally like line
them around there and just give you more
stuff to search for but no if there's a
landing zone it has it as soon as you
leave that landing zone don't even go
look that's just the way it's been it's
really weird i kind of wondered why that
is is there a reason you have to find
them is it for a triumph i don't know if
there's a triumph to eventually find
them all because i know there's a lot of
secret triumphs right now i've been just
going through and looking for all of
them each week is just kind of a video
as they unlock so like next week i don't
know if there's going to be any more
since we're probably going to go back to
edc now there will be more potentially
in the shattered realm because we've
been getting those unlocks but on patrol
yeah like as soon as it rotates a week
people like oh i can't go to the edc and
get them anymore it's like nope so they
seem tied to the week of rotation
and then new red said there is a trap
yes so i think that's part of it that's
weird
yeah i've uh
what's weird is that step in the quest
for me it said go to the moon and get
ascendant you know snow drops whatever
the heck they're called
uh and
tear drops i don't i don't know what
they are they're anchors like i go and i
anchors as soon as i land in the zone it
completes that step for me yes it
automatically completely you went to the
moon now go one of those
parts and i never get any of them
one of the parts of the quest is
literally go to that planet
they want you to land on the planet as
part of the quest because you don't have
to get any of them it doesn't seem like
you have to get all of them but it tells
you kind of where it wants you to land
so you
kind of know they're there you know it
doesn't make you get enemies i've never
picked one up yeah it's a glitch it
almost acts like sometimes it you
retroactively pick something up that you
never pick something up because i had
that same thing happen to me travel i'm
like they like go to this planet and go
get the anchors and i'm like all right
i'll go to the tango shore i land yeah
you did it next step i'm like what i
didn't grab anything
like it completes in the upper right
hand corner i'm like all right if you
say so i'll do the next step then
yeah i don't know if it's based on like
if you did any if you did any on like
the first week and found some on
european dead zone when it wanted you to
fight maybe
maybe electro-active weekly chat then it
may count as like hey you've already
picked up some
it's not counting like a total unless
you're going after the triumph so the
quest if you've got some move it on
so i think that's more than anything um
shattered realm with the hive still
pretty cool
um got a little surprised they didn't
actually notice the champion was gonna
be barrier so like mid-fight i was like
oh gotta switch but it didn't matter i
just pulled out my fusion rifle the
particle deconstruction
oh i just i just honestly pulled no
composure no just the basic fusion rifle
of fusion rifles
just deletes
like it doesn't matter
any fusion rifle with that thing i went
through and was doing a test video
yesterday and the way regular
regular fusion rifle versus a linear
fusion rifle same amount i went into
lost sector i was doing just a regular
lost sector and i was trying to see how
fast i could kill the boss and i was
doing it on
i think it was normal difficulty but
yeah it was just to see and linear
fusion rifle you can see the numbers pop
up but like the first shot you do with a
normal fusion rifle
stacks it fully i think if it doesn't
it's like the first one or the other one
so every shot after the first shot is
440 percent more it's not like a linear
is like 10 20 30 40 it stacks up the
normal fusion just like
first one okay everything else 40 40 40.
and it's just i just start melting stuff
i was going through and just like
testing on
just an unstoppable champion hit him
with that one and that was on like a
legend nightmare hunter was just trying
to find like one guy that i would stun i
was like all right so
without the fusion rifle
hit him stun him one two three then he
killed me
right and then i turned around with
particle deconstruction one two dead
just like dead and three i was like my
god it's just awesome
you can melt so much stuff so fast
that's like if you've done it to any of
the tanks if you come across like
you know a strike it with a tank in it
anywhere
just it's over
i was doing whatever the nightfall was
um
hollowed lair when you have the tank in
the middle there just deleted it
absolutely just deleted it so
particle deconstruction is crazy uh i've
seen a different build that people have
been messing with where it's making like
just crap tons of orbs
or with the solar melees and i can
honestly see like a titan just throwing
a hammer everywhere making solar orbs
like all over the place there's some
interesting builds and then you've got
solar weapons with vex stacking with
like the solar boots for a titan
there's some interesting builds going
right now
iron banner last week with the tease of
the set bonus please give me more of
that
there's a titan build did y'all see that
one with taraba and those boots i got
yeah
oh god no oh it's crazy sounds hilarious
it's crazy yeah yeah yeah i gotta i got
some serious bills to continue
but yeah i mean shattered realm's been
fun i think
you know it's like when we go back in
next week now we're gonna have true
sight we're also gonna have safe passage
and then we're gonna kind of get the
last two so when we get to week six i
don't know how much more we're gonna get
besides when we start getting those
exotic i'm guessing we'll get the exotic
quest go through pick up the weapon and
then the catalyst is probably going to
be
shoot all the walls everywhere to kind
of open everything up and maybe sit hit
maybe the catalyst is fine all the
chests all the anchors and that type of
thing
we'll see if that makes a difference
because there's stuff that's still
hidden in there i know that
i want to shout them out because we we
definitely were very hard on them bungie
in reference to
we which was legit we had a big point of
contention with the parallax
um amount that you can hold
right
and not only did they they increased
that threshold right because the thing i
like about seasonal loss focusing system
versus the other one i like that i can
do my daily activities whether it be the
playlist activity strikes crucible yes
and i can still yeah get that currency
so it's letting me get the currency by
playing the game for the most part
normally and then i can stack and then i
can go in there and use that currency to
focus my m grams and then upgrade the
little thing and stuff like that so i
actually like it i actually like this
better you gotta be kind of thing and
shout out to them for being quick
or cause i thought they were gonna time
gate us with that that annoying what was
it what was it before like what does
that mean
was it it's 1500
1500
i'd play like a couple of iron banner
matches forget
you know that i had it capped because
you know what you cap you got to rush
and spend it so it was just such an
annoying cycle to go back to the helm
and do that shout out to them for
increasing that that that was a good
on-the-fly change and i like it so i've
been liking the grind in that in that
case i wish they would raise the cap on
the tier threes a bit more as well
because it is so accessible to earn oh
my god like the tier threes is you get
four and that's worth six hundred so too
expensive yeah nine hundred six hundred
nine hundred down six hundred and and
one six hundred for two two yeah and one
of the two tier two is 450. it's like
450. one of the triumphs is like
focusing
on umbrella three times you gotta do two
or two yeah you gotta do tier two yeah
yeah cause i messed up and did tier one
on the second time two dude i spent i
spent all night yep same thing so
annoyed you know next week it's gonna be
due tier three which means we're gonna
have to play what six crucible matches
to get one like that's yep
but at least it's playlist activities at
least it's
within and you could get kills by
getting you can still kill people just
play the game is how i feel it yeah so i
don't i don't get too crazy with that
but when they forced me to be like
you've got to do a zillion what's that
wax
yeah
he's so disrespectful
but yeah what was this the six-man
activity last season dave over that one
yeah like they're like you've got to do
override you've got to do this like i
hate being locked into that like that
gets annoying you know what i'm saying
but this one no i'm cool i was gonna ask
you how you guys feel about um
i know astral alignment and the changes
i'm as far as the bosses the encounters
like apparently there's just two
oh
there's just two bosses we've seen both
of them now because we're back to the
first one
um
yeah yeah they're
it's
i like the teleporty projection guy more
okay then
the other one where you go to the
blight take the little thing shoot down
the shield and then he just
dies
he dies fast the other guy like you
gotta chase him around for a while so
it's a bit more but the other guy when
you break that shield if you get it
broken people are now just like deleted
he's so
dead
yeah but i mean it's
those are like i'm glad they're not
overbearing that one too much okay
because as you said when you do override
over it over and over right over it just
to get the currency to both focus
umbrals and i kind of we're still
focusing on bros was not related to just
the seasonal currency yeah why i got it
because you got the same currency
because now like the unlocks on the uh
compass those are
like t the third the fourth fifth and
sixth row and whatever the last one
which is like that's like week 12
whenever you get to that one um but
they're like 600 each as well and you're
trying to unlock those so shattered arms
more accessible stuff last longer so
you're like do i want this one or do i
want another tier three well if i use
tier three then tier two well i gotta do
these triumphs over here but i wanna
if we play it and the only way to solve
it is to play more destiny yeah yeah
that's actually yeah
that's exactly what i was gonna say is
like we can probably squeeze in a decent
amount of time on the game depending on
what your schedule is like but if
somebody's trying to like really make
this like you know they got a lot going
on they get to play a few hours on a
weekend here like you know busy parent
whatever it may be
they're asking for a lot of time still
to do
all of the stuff that's involved i know
some of it's more for
you know your hardcores your people who
play a lot your you know content
creators whatever it may be they're
giving different levels but
there's a a certain point where somebody
who doesn't get to play as often is
definitely going to feel very limited in
what they're capable of doing
because the currency goes both ways like
hey i want to unlock this thing well
what if it was
i don't know
like 20
legend what are the enhancement cores or
whatever those like the basic thing i
have like 1800 of or whatever what if
those were a little more option or there
was different and then the currency
itself went into the artifact it's just
we're the currency are you proposing
that bungie use their currencies
what is they actually have bungie has 50
currencies and they're all not used
yeah
they have a ton
yeah we haven't had how many how many
seasonal currencies do we have in our
inventory is it four i mean we probably
do we still have last season's currently
we still have last season's curry i
still have those decrypted data things
for the the team is there even a way to
get more of those oh i guess you could
do that
yeah i guess yeah they still drop
like if you're not because i'm capped at
five yeah
i've got like 350 the corrupted key
codes i've got five of those i'm
literally looking right now to see
what's sitting in there right now uh
parallax i went to go pilot pull a
tincture of queensfoil i was like do i
have those i actually did but i was like
oh
i actually did an ascendant uh an
ascendant challenge like those old
school ones from three years ago oh you
took it you took it back
i was like do i even remember where this
is and i was like okay yeah i think i
know where it was and i still remembered
but it's just it just kind of cracks me
up of like as you said yeah there's a
lot of currencies just
chilling out there
kind of waiting for a thing there's
still an ascendant lens from festival of
the lost 2020
what the hell is that i don't understand
i've got a glittering key for the
dreaming city somebody probably knows
what some of the stuff is for but
it is yeah it's just a weird state of
and i'm wondering it's like when we go
to like which queen is just like and
wipe the slate clean and i honestly
wonder because this season we're gonna
spend a lot of time and i'm probably
gonna be like yeah you can get rid of it
but it is still gonna be weird to go
go into witch queen and then we lose all
of our seasonal stuff because
every activity we've been doing override
expunge pressage harbinger
and now we've got shattered realm which
is fantastic you've got the astral
alignment all the stuff they've worked
on for the year
theoretically gone do you guys think
that's how it's really going to go
i'm honestly curious
but you're taking time yes i think
that's what's going to happen yeah i
think they'll probably take the
opportunity to vault a bunch of other
stuff like forsaken that they haven't
talked about yet because they haven't
addressed any of that yet and usually
when bungie doesn't address stuff it's
because
the news is bad and they're waiting for
take out the trash day you know
friday friday at 9 00 pm uh
yeah friday at 9pm take out the trash
take out the trash make everybody smell
it and then give them some good news
right after right uh
yeah so i i i think all that stuff is
gone and i think probably forsaken
content is gone there's probably other
stuff there's sun setting that they
haven't talked to us about yet but
that's gonna hurt but it's gonna be so
much to lose
they're adding a lot of stuff yeah i
wouldn't be surprised if they put the uh
cosmodrome back in
it makes sense i mean actually i guess i
don't think they're gonna do that
because they're they're putting the
dungeon there they're putting the
dungeon there i forgot about that
yeah so you know that one's staying
that's also a recent addition city
dreaming city and tangled shore they
could get rid of them man that's a lot
that's a lot of content
i mean if you go old destinations i
haven't seen like them do a whole lot of
anything with nessus in a while
i don't know if there's a reason to keep
that planet around it's one of the
bigger ones i know
um
edz still seems like it's like earth i
don't know if that one's ever really
going to go because old chicago
rumored and otherwise isn't going to
like overlap with earth too much
so i think you can still keep that
destination but like
nessus is truly its own like palette and
everything
i don't know how many strikes are on
that one that's another thing i don't
even know how many strikes we're going
to get with which queen
hmm
good point true i haven't talked about
it we're talking about having that yet
too and then the last question i thought
about before we started my shirt is
gambit
are they going to do anything with
gambit for witch queen because they've
mentioned crucible maps at this point
they haven't mentioned the gambit map
look man gambit yakichu yaku wait you're
not getting it yeah yeah i could wait
listen y'all
in that
get in yeah exactly get in line i'm not
liking it it's our time
i'm not a huge gambit champion you're
wearing the shirt i have a lot of bungee
shirts okay
but all i'm saying is like i've never
seen you wear a crucible once that's
what i'm saying i definitely have talked
to him
i haven't you know it i've got a shack
shirt on top of anything else
and i've got to try i'll show you stop
that's not pvp i've got a triangle shirt
yeah yeah i've seen that's obviously
that one debut yet continue yeah i've
literally won all of these i've said
have been on the podcast just go look at
the receipts it's fine
uh no but honestly i was just wondering
because they do tend to keep us in the
playlist like strikes we'll probably get
some missions that turn into strikes i
would imagine they'll probably do
something there might be a couple like
there's probably going to be a strike or
two in her realm crucible we kind of
have a plan for maps a little revamp in
some systems
gambit truly does feel like
it is like the long forgotten drowned
skeleton like it is i don't honestly i
honestly i don't know if they would
sunset because it's kind of one of their
three pillars but also if they don't and
we still have four maps i'm just kind of
wondering
if you're gonna make us keep going
through that even as a pinnacle thing
like that's one of your plus one
pinnacles just an easy one to do but
you're like so easy why not complain no
but it's it's i'm like pro game it is
such a breeze to do three matches bro i
like fix your facial i love it love when
i have to jump in there it is so quick
it's either you're melting their melting
game over and that means
whatever oh yeah that stuff's gonna die
now
you like it because it's over fast yes
it's uh it's it's like it's not attached
that's your reason for liking it yes
that is easy
there's probably a joke and a metaphor
to other things in life that i could
throw out there but i just can't come up
with right now
cog what else do
[Laughter]
we really did i'm sorry guys that's okay
oh i was hilarious
i thought of it but i didn't say
anything until he
made a comment i was like all right now
i got it
yeah i was kind of walking around it and
i was like all right we're going
straight for it we're going for this oh
no yeah
anyway good good good why are you you're
so frustrated with gaming don't ask the
truth
efficiency
exactly yeah it's all about that's like
teddy i'm sure teddy thinks of it that
way she's just like
i need to procreation and then in and
out
fast and sad not the fast and furious oh
my goodness
my problem with gambit is that it's not
a fun game mode and it's supremely
imbalanced and it doesn't have a lot of
maps and they've given it no attention
and there's no real reason to do it like
there's just so many problems with it
and the fact that it's over quickly that
seems to be their fix for it is like
well let's at least make it just short
and that way people don't have to like
struggle against it for a really long
period of time which granted it being
long as well is also bad i just think
like they either need to commit to that
or not and i'm i'm with e that like
something needs to happen with it uh but
you know like cog and i said get in line
like it just you guys don't get to do
this oh yeah i'm not saying it comes
from before crucible but it is this like
it is now the the left out to pasture
just to die i think yeah it is uh
somebody in the comments said that
bungie has already said no new crucible
or gambit maps at launch so
uh which i i think we already knew there
were no crucible maps at launch they're
sort of coming in over time but uh
yeah
interesting stuff it just feels weird
when you're like hey look slowly working
on your pinnacles because that's all we
do now per seasons if they stick with
the 10 model
what are some of your easy pinnacles
strikes crucible but that gambit just
sits out there and i'm like
yeah i mean part of me for the
challenges too with the seasonal
challenges i hate having it stare at me
all all season but if like these if
they're not going to be retroactive
like if i go through and i play like six
matches or do a reset or whatever and it
doesn't count
you know beat 50
whatever it is if it doesn't count what
i've done throughout the season i don't
want to touch it until later so then
it's just this little little yellow dot
that stares at me the whole time
but i was like i also don't want to put
time into it if i care about doing some
challenges later i may as well just do
them all at once
so it's just weird that was all just
random i was thinking about i was like i
know crucible's not getting a lot
they're messing with some stuff though
trials getting some love coming up but
man gambit i was like it really is in
the bottom of the barrel now
yeah it's definitely probably ours yeah
it's a travis point i don't want to you
know poo-poo what he's saying like yeah
it's we know the mode needs work you
know we know there's things that need to
happen to it adjustments it needs to
refresh on some level obviously the
reason why i don't have too much
sympathy for them they had a whole
gambit prime season they had a season of
the gambit they had armor they had all
this stuff that crucible never had and i
really don't care that they gonna have
to wait like i just don't like that
listen
i was at the debut sorry oh e but i was
at the debut
um
gambit thing shout out to sean finnegan
and dustin i was there when gambit
debuted and it was a mode and they were
like bloviating about all this stuff
they're gonna be doing for it and it was
great don't get me wrong and it was a
new mall but they could wait
it's cool it will get addressed at some
point and to until until their credit
they still been getting a steady
um loop pull they always get fly weapons
in game even if even to this day you got
that the 260 um scout that's in this
servant whatever the thing is
really good you got bottom dollar in
there they gambit weapons be good like
low-key
right they have to maybe
good bad or otherwise but like they have
to give you a big ass carrot for you to
think about playing gambit and that's
kind of the only thing they have is the
weapons so i hear you all i'm saying is
i've been doing um what's called glory i
ain't getting like since the mountaintop
days and all that why are you doing
glory just for entertainment value just
for the pinnacle because they telling me
to go in there they force me it's not
even a pinnacle it's powerful
in your core playlist of control
elimination rumble and the weekly
rotator glory is a powerful which is
even worse
100
the comp one yes it is powerful it is
win seven rounds for a powerful
it used to be pinnacle why do i think
it's a pain it's been powerful for a
while because of making how to level up
videos for a good year no i trust you no
but that one is okay and that's the sad
part is that i just looked it up and it
says it says shut up ebontis
look at the end of the day it's seven
matches i gotta get in there please but
it's powerful you don't need your two is
all i'm saying brah we're not doing that
here's the thing don't you we get out of
here with you your casual crucible self
at the end of the day
i gotta get in there and win seven
matches against sweaties and all type of
randomness
first off
and
i don't get any seven rounds and i don't
get any unique loot oh i'm not i'm not
arguing that it's like
it means that should be a pinnacle and
that should have like stages to they
should do something there's what i was
waiting to get to because yes it's
really sad that of all the things on
that list that hang out every week
that should be a pinnacle you can do
three matches of control and you can win
seven rounds in
competitive you know glory playlist and
you can't get a pinnacle out of that
that is a travesty
so much that i still go in there and i
would just like hey it would be cool
like how gambit has unique gambit loot
you know what i'm saying like that's all
that's all i'm saying but yeah that's it
i mean at the end of the day
gimmick could wait
that's it gary could wait that's that's
tomorrow let's start great
[Laughter]
oh man um
but also today actually i wanted to ask
you guys kind of on a separate note
since
um
destiny is seven years old today
and
it's been a hell of a journey i even saw
that and i was just trying to think back
i was like what i was doing seven years
ago what i've been through in the past
seven years
and it's been quite interesting and i
wanted to ask you guys
just in general
what has destiny meant to you over the
past seven years just in general either
of you guys want to start
how it's changed you what you've been
through what you were doing seven years
ago
what what is destiny meant to you guys
in the past seven years
draft what does it mean to me
what is destiny
what is it what is what it's not
jeopardy
okay
is it a is it a like a jenga
a board have you played shoots and
letters it's not that are you okay
are you sure
um
uh destiny to me i mean it's been a
life-changing experience right like
both on a personal and a professional
note like
i would
you know i'd probably be working for ign
but i wouldn't
not to the extent that i am without
destiny because fire team chat was
really my foot in the door
um
i wouldn't have the same friends that i
have i wouldn't be friends with you guys
i would be friends with lots of people
that i know personally
and uh professionally just like because
that's how people connect um i went to
somebody's wedding who i met in destiny
like and i only met him once in person
and flew across the country to go to his
wedding met him in destiny um so i i
think it's really hard to answer that
question because
i can't really even imagine what my life
would be like without it
and that is the saddest sentence i've
ever said as a 31 year old man i can't
imagine my life without destiny the
video game um but it's true man it's
really true i i
the people i know the way i spend my
time the friends that i have the
uh ties that i own the um
the career i have at ign like a lot of
it is linked to the fact that destiny
was made so
well said sir well said god
yeah feels feels seven years right like
um
i still to this day say i've never
played a game this long and this
passionately i've just it's just there's
no other game like it you know i was
just on we just did recorded defining
duke and um one of the questions that
came in for me was like hey [ __ ] we know
you as the destiny guy you know
what is it about it and stuff like that
and remember when deej had that uh thing
and he's like the friendship game and it
was a joke at the time but it is it's
the friends game it it really is it
really is it really is friend gamers the
end game is the front game the end game
is like on some level at that time that
comment wasn't well received because we
wanted new stuff i think yeah a little
bit i always thought people were i
always thought people were being harsh
we got to stop everything
we got we got a young goat in there get
him we got the man with the tin foil
spin foil cb gray with the three dollar
super chat thank you for the love sir
shout out to another man we yeah i was
like we'll get to mine but it's like
yeah another man who's been on this
podcast a great gentleman and just a
kind kind man thank you cb great for the
love in chat
appreciate thank you cb good dude shout
out to you like look at that like cb's
in here and um i was just watching a
video with him
jigsaw clyde a ton of destiny
contributors going on a trip
having a ball right i got my homie you
know we got we got dj in there david
orros in here i just met him in real
life you know
last weekend you know what i'm saying he
drove from pittsburgh like he's i'm not
too far from his town he pulls up
destiny in the building oh shout out to
the osiris judge you hook me up bro that
was like you got i got the little cyrus
video that was dope but anyway but uh
yeah it was fire shot dick you know i
said but it's like e you know our
history right i mean yeah you and i
we wouldn't be on this thing without
this game i mean we went to a convention
about a single game
because we're a little crazy in tampa in
the summer sweating our ass off
outside in line passing out business
cards because they're the two crazy ones
you decided to do that we're in the
tampa fairgrounds and like early on i
remember seeing datto stand in a line
crazy long
you meet people half of them are shorter
than you think the other people you're
like hi
i was like i got to see guardian radio
was like literally the first podcast i
ever listened to and since then i've
found like so many gaming podcasts i
think i listened to like almost all the
ign podcasts
um
it's been so i mean
as you guys said i literally stopped
kickboxing today
and i was like but it's something i'm
able to still help support my household
because of this game because of the
journey i've been through between
streaming and making videos in the
content creation and
all the amazing people like the number
of guests that we've had on this podcast
i'm like starting to lose track of all
of i mean i've got a list somewhere but
it's like the number of awesome people
that we've got to spend a couple of
hours with to have like a legit
conversation get to know him talk about
about this game we love really kind of
break down walls and have fun and now
like one of our really good friends
i can call travis just the fact that
he's on this podcast with us to share
this journey
like we were lucky enough that hey it's
like you know we talk all the time we
got guests on here and we have a blast
with him on and then all of a sudden
it's like
just because you know ign goes a
different direction
we give him an outlet to talk about
destiny even more than he did before he
gets two hours instead of one so it's
like he gets to talk even more he gets
to fill you know he gets to make up a
segment in a different place now so
no it's like it's been
it's been like so many people that we
met like gcx next year
if it gets to happen because again we
don't know with what's going to happen
in the world but gcx next year is going
to be something else because it's been
long overdue a podcast has been blown up
the number of people that we've met the
bond the what we've all been through in
the past especially a couple of years as
well
and it's and it all started because this
alpha beta whatever you started playing
the game roaming around in destiny 1 in
the cosmodrome and shooting tanks and
doing public events
and the devil's lair strike and it all
started there and i'm just like damn
it's it's just crazy to think about is
that the story of how you guys met we
yeah it's you guys met at gcm met at gcx
and 20 god what was that 16
20. there was a big break
you you guys you guys just started
talking or like i need to know this oh
you didn't know the story oh all right
so from my perspective was kind of just
what he said like
i don't know i was like look i l like
real quick before i give you the e-story
i just got to give you my backstory real
quick with the destiny seven years love
date is that
i was remember initially like a hater of
the game because i played it like a
traditional game thinking it was you
start and finish and i was done so this
is before like the forever 30 days and
then sinister hits me and it's like bro
you got to do the raid and i'm like for
what like you know i do it i get
mesmerized i'm like okay i see the
potential of this game fog changed my
life and then i kept going then you have
to take your king moments and so on and
so forth and now i am like the staunch
defender of the game right
anyone slanders i'm in a timeline i'm
i'm pulling out facts i'm i'm pulling
out this i'm the person's like oh if
destiny's such a dead game how come it's
top 10 on xbox live most gameplay always
consistent number two is number three
like i was that dude i i ended up
becoming like the super fan boy and i
you know
yeah i was clearly i was in my bag right
so what ends up happening was i'm like
damn i love this game so much i'm
defending this game so much which i'm
weird because i was officially hated and
then i hear about
this convention this guardian con
destiny khan at the time that's the
economy was called back then tampa bay
fairgrounds days so i'm like
if i call myself a real destiny fan how
could i not go to the destiny convention
how could i not be with my brothers and
sisters that share this passion about so
i got to do it right so i'm like are
looking at the take some look at i know
no one like and that's one thing about
me even king will tell you like i'm a
very bold person if i'm passionate i'll
fly across the country to do something
yeah you know we both i went completely
by myself knew not a soul i knew some
content creators i knew guardian radio a
little bit i actually like but yeah i
was like i knew i literally went by
myself had this like
craptacular airbnb
single room shared i was like i don't
even feel great in this weird airbnb
that i'm at in tampa yeah that was weird
anyways continue never go to tampa for
nothing does anyone feel great in tampa
party anybody who lives there
no i'm sitting i'm like all right i get
the information at the time
my resources were guardium radio right
and
planet that's the early planet yesterday
when when taft and all those guys were
all under one roof there so that was my
weekly bible to get information on the
game and and learning about rhinoceros
yeah that was me so then i go i fly out
there remember we stand in that hot that
hot ass up oh that's like
oh god like i didn't know about florida
heat and deal out and humidity until i
went to tampa so out there i'm like all
right so we finally get in big
convention everyone's geeked out they
got their you know destiny stuff for the
t-shirts and all that i'm like i love my
brothers and sisters so i see the
guardian radio booth i'm like oh spiff
you know homies you know what i said um
well we forget my man talk box
yeah
what's up oh um sean macy sean
oh what's the last one i'm trying to
remember
yeah why are we blanking you know who
i'm talking about too yeah the dad that
guy yeah yeah uh you know who it is
i apologize i apologize
we know we know we know we apologize so
anyway so we i'll go to that booth
so you know you do what you take you
don't know
the guardian radio original crew was
mark turcotte
get up get up k-dub
mesa shawn
bife was part of them he was like in and
out yeah and then they had another and
the bell bunnies and then the science
body and then uh scientist guy for nasa
so at that time it's guardian radio and
planet destiny are like the de facto
podcast information you get if you want
to know about destiny at that time so i
go over to that both you know you do
your little pictures memes of everybody
that's all right do i pick so while
that's going on i see e right so i hear
him talking or whatever whatever and
then i think i may introduce myself to
you
we're we were both passing out business
cards in the line everybody's waiting to
get in
yes you're right and we were both
passing out business cards just saying
hey you know i'm a content creator
youtuber i don't even i was small at
that point too
no not bro he's bigger than me
barely he's like like 100
i was 100 sub iron lord podcast like we
were like bro it was like i was in awe
of e because i remember when like i he
gave me his card and i looked at it i
was like oh wow he's got like you're
like at least 10k 20k at that point at
least me i'm gonna say i don't know i
don't know what was you at what were you
at that time
i'd have to i'd have to honestly go pet
go back and check because it was small
for you
bro i was not that big like you had to
release 10k at least i don't think so i
really don't at that point probably felt
like 10k it was bro whatever his number
was wow that's ten times what i thought
that might have been it might have been
it might have been like 1600 or
something you were like whoa dude bro
whatever his number was i was like
wow
that must be nice to even to even get to
that like that's insane he's cool with
me
i was like wow this is awesome so anyway
so i go around we exchange business
cards we talk whatever and as we're
talking about like yo isn't this dope
isn't this cool like holy and then we
just you know shoot a [ __ ] and then yeah
having fun and then i remember they did
they did like a after
party thing event right then they like
we go out meet up for the drinks or
something remember there was another
yeah yep post convention yeah and then
also that same one travis you'll
appreciate this
oh
i saw some igf igf i teach early stages
destin
sean finnegan i don't know i believe him
no it was it was destined fran mirabella
was there yes fran
destin and i'm going to say it was
finnegan at the time if he was there i
didn't meet him i only have that
chocolate first here
was there at the time so dan i go up
there in my little business card
hey i'm cognito
whatever whatever you know hey what's up
ted i still have the pictures i'll put
it up on twitter i still got the
pictures of back then early con dustin
and the crew and i was like i was so
happy man i was like oh this is dope
kind of thing but yeah then from there
went to the after party joint with
exchange business and then me and e i
was like bro like you know this kid
knows his destiny it was so fun and like
i said no game had ever made me do that
and then to this day like you know
obviously we start at the time you know
i'm saying flash point you know i hit up
i hit up e and i'm like yo you want to
do a destiny podcast this is cursive
osiris mind you this is my literally the
game is dead everyone's angry
f this game
and i'm just like yo i love this game
too much we we got to fight for it right
yeah then we we did it we did it man it
was yeah no game no game is like this
it's
a lot of it sometimes just logging in
and catching up with the homies a lot of
it is just the shooting mechanics the
great music
and when destiny's good there's nothing
nothing comparable it it literally shuts
everything down for me i'm always going
to ride for and we got a chance to be
bungee portassi teddy you name it the
the the who's who of the community have
all met us and it's been tremendous
that's why he is saying like i cannot
wait
for gcx e3 please cancel because i would
like to go to gcx and say i'm just
saying e3 just you know if you decide to
not have e3 i wouldn't be sad because i
really want to go to g6 and i don't like
the fact that you were the same time
frame as gcx but that's just me
no i mean you covered a lot like our
history of like meeting out there g6 and
everything but yes you're starting this
beta i had a group of i have a really
good friend i'm still hanging out with
literally all the time locally with him
um but we had a group he worked at
gamestop at the time he had some friends
we all started raiding
like we had like a regular tuesday group
that we'd run through he had like nine
gal horns before i ever got my first one
oh my like my run at that was awful um
but it was like and then you know it got
to the point where you do taken king and
then you have curse levels and then you
have like the rise of iron still being
pretty good but people start falling
like taking king some people played and
then as soon as that kind of died off
people started falling off hard
and that was when it really started
changing was after taking king you'd
lose some and then my friend would come
back for some games and then leave and
then i'd still be playing i was like
okay well what do i do in this game now
let me
solo nightfalls just for entertainment
value just to like see if i can do these
by myself and then i was like
i sold them before like it was ever a
content thing that i did and back then
it was different because modifiers and
champions all that crazy stuff now but
it was like you know i still remember
the shield brothers i could tell you at
about 180 to 190 000 damage you put it
into the first guy he'd march out of the
room then you have these guys spawn like
i know that i played that one so many
times
because it was like when i would record
when i finally got to that point i
wanted a flawless recording so if i
died start all the way over and i got a
whole bunch of practice in those but
that was also like the first time i did
that and people appreciated hey i
appreciate the live commentary you're
very calm when you do this appreciate
that like you can keep this together you
really helped me it's like just the and
i guess that kind of goes in the same
with like teaching kickboxing and stuff
like that it's like apparently kind of
like helping some point some way somehow
it's kind of part of it and it's just
one of those things that i guess works
for me i don't know if i'm always the
best teacher i'm probably a little bro
like blunt at some points but i was like
in general it is
it's been an interesting experience to
see like how
something i don't picture myself doing
and then all of a sudden you just start
trying and then you're meeting people
and then you go to gcx and you have like
i remember pyrogaming which i haven't
even seen him that much i know he had
some like twitter issues he gave me like
my first shout out and i was like
watching my subs i was like
what is happening right now because it
was just like ding ding ding ding ding
ding i was like and they're like hey uh
you know shout out from pyrogaming and i
literally
looked him up reached out you know ended
up playing with him off and on over the
years and everything like that i don't
know what i was like i know he's been
doing other stuff now lately but i was
like that was like the first shout out
and he just like dude this guy's got
great detail in his videos
and then you know it jumps up from there
and then obviously for me it's like gcx
was amazing and then
whisper for me was
crazy
with my and it wasn't even when it first
came out
like my voice
video was like a year late
that was the crazy part because when i
did it is when
like it came back to being a thing and
it was when i was like i'll just try and
do it now is when heavy ammo was like
really hardly dropping at all
and it was that point where it's like
whatever youtube magical algorithm
alignment of the stars happened on that
video
it went so crazy i didn't even
understand what was happening i was on
like the youtube
creator of the day
i was like nice so i was like and again
the other videos they posted on there
were tiny and just like i'm like just
there's one good video in the rest of my
questions why am i even here it's like
imposter syndrome the entire way through
this whole thing and it still feels like
that sometimes so
it's i don't know it's been one of those
things i never pictured myself doing to
be on a podcast to have i mean i'm the
guy who didn't want to get up in front
of the room and like
give a presentation in class stage
fright's hell just nervous as can be
like absolutely and then you get into
this thing where you're comfortable
you've got chat that's cool but it
doesn't feel in the same way between
this and kickboxing nerves are i'd
probably still be a little nervous
talking to like like an auditorium or
something at that point but i mean the
same thing you know you get to go on
stage recently as well but it's just
like
coming out of my shell and stuff and
there's just so much that is
it's stupid to say all this about a
video game as travis you said in the
beginning it is you're like this is a
freaking video game but in turn
you think about the seven years and what
you've been through with it what you've
changed like the people the experiences
as you said you flew across the country
to go to a wedding like there's gonna be
a point we meet you we gotta go visit
san francisco and hang out in your crib
yeah we gotta get cosmina literally like
crashed at my house before he went to a
wedding he's met my dogs and my wife
like from this so it's like
it's crazy so i was like yeah this is
like a weird nostalgia episode between
like
weird job day as i said emotional
rollercoaster all day and apparently
we're gonna continue with that as is but
yeah you the train nah listen everything
you said was perfect and last point i'll
say is like we got to give bungie their
flowers at the end of the day
you know
listen we complain we have our issues
this game has ups and downs you know but
we have to give credit to the endurance
of the game and and how it continues to
evolve and still we say it all the time
like we could complain we can pitch but
when we see that that that new trailer
for whatever is about to drop
it brings it all back and one thing i
love is when people come to us and say
hey i'm thinking about shout outs to the
cops they're excited too
but they're thinking about like yo i'm
thinking about playing destiny you know
i wanna let me know like what do you
guys think and they they come to us
right you you ever noticed like you you
ended up you end up being the
spokesperson for destiny trav like do
you ever people come up to you randomly
and it's just like yo
trav i know you love it right
it's like a dragon i'll think about
trying
somebody who
no one on that podcast plays destiny and
somebody in the audience asks like yo
what do you recommend for getting back
to destiny i was like don't do it
and i had a whole list i was just like
it'll absorb your life it's impossible
you're going to have like 90 currencies
you understand just wait for which queen
like just don't do it so
i'm like the opposite of you but yeah i
definitely know that situation yeah it's
it's it's a great game man it's a great
game and i'm excited for the future the
music the gun play all the stuff that we
love the dungeons the raids the pvp the
trials
seven years man keep on going i'm glad
i'm glad i know your story now i know
how osiris met st
[Laughter]
oh my god
you were savvy it's beautiful
[Laughter]
i went through time with space to to be
a tamper yes yes yeah that's right i
created this actually literally
[Laughter]
you went to sweltering yeah
hot tampa down there for me
that's right salute destiny seven years
man phenomenal yeah if you guys haven't
checked it out they've got a really good
website article up on the bungie blog
just the seventh anniversary there's
some really cool concept art you guys
see like original like renders of what
like cabal areas could look like and you
can see i remember like the subterranean
areas uh like i miss those and stuff
like when you go look through you've got
really rough sketches of what mars and
the vex look like and
you know hunter cloaks that don't look
like that now i think those are hunter
cloaks but they're much like bigger and
sweeping
just some very very cool to go back and
think like yeah i kind of kind of
recognize all this stuff and they have
the different releases and the trailers
for like the dark below and house of
wolves and
yeah
just go back and watch some of that
stuff and if you've been playing for a
while
you kind of see why we're all losing our
mind when it comes to like hey which
queen why is this such a big deal
because they do it every time
oh yeah
it's it's big um
but yeah twap this wheat obviously
touched on that one first
that was probably what i would call the
biggest piece i would say of the 12 is
just like breaking down and then they
got into what is coming up tomorrow
and we definitely talked about it plenty
with regards to last week changes for
trials come in they talk about the
revamp you know the rounds are going to
be shorter obviously they did mention
the weapon and this is going to be the
new legendary linear fusion rifle uh we
know those are in a really good spot
right now particle deconstructor this
one is called
reeds regret and it is a stasis
packing some stasis damage apparently
but if it's a linear fusion rifle
is it going to be in the kinetic
slaughter the heavy slot
got to be heavy right
i would think so so i would think it's
happening
wait a minute you're right because they
said stasis weapons would be all
yo
[Music]
it'll be interesting there's a chance if
it's a legendary linear fusion that
could be like
kind of important just to try and get
three wins
are there any legendary
well there's no are there any fusion
there's arbor left in the kinetic but
it's exotic yeah
it'll be interesting i don't think i
don't think but i don't think there's
any linear fusion rifles in any special
slot if they unless they're exotic no i
mean i looked on light.gg and it shows
it as a power weapon so i mean okay okay
but it is yeah
is it it's funny which i agree what
you're saying because i remember didn't
they made this statement that
all stasis weapons would be in the
kinetic slot so it is interesting right
yeah well we already have a stasis power
weapon
i mean we do well that's the difference
but that one is actually that's the one
that actually shoots the ice crystals
this is just like stasis linear fusion
and i kind of like when it was in the
kinetic i could kind of understand it's
not like stasis bullets it's got more of
the stasis
perks
this one isn't specifically gonna be
it's got like you know the curated has
headstone on it which you know everybody
wants you got a chance at vorpal firing
line rampage
uh clown cartridge triple tap he i mean
you've got some really good options
especially like you get vorpal on a
heavy already
i am affordable
is definitely going to be a good thing
for sure
this is going to this is definitely
going to get me into that match made
playlist that used to be called trials
we did all that last week but yeah it's
like trials is
you know you're gonna have the passages
are gonna be different you've got the
different wins the seven win challenge
the weekly bounties are gone you've got
the ranking system uh the rounds are
going to be shorter cross play is going
to be enabled
and you've also got the the different
barriers you've got the paywall you have
to own beyond light so hopefully that's
going to limit a lot of the cheaters
battle eyes already putting in some work
which they've mentioned it's not like
you know full swing but they've
definitely already had some work done
from battle eye you've got the going
after account recoveries you've got the
win trading some of that stuff's harder
to track but alone
you have to own beyond light
yes it is not free to play anymore and i
think
that one piece alone is gonna be a big
detriment to cheaters because how many
times you're gonna spend 40 just to try
and earn it back if you get caught like
what's the right like how many times are
you potentially gonna get burned
before it kind of screws you and that's
why i'm hoping same thing by like
battlefield hopefully doesn't have
cheaters if it's a full 60 70 dollar
game
hopefully it's the same boat but
i mean that's i i'm going to try it this
weekend now granted i also want to play
the new world beta but
we'll see where my time goes
you get that
yeah it's going to slide into that
casual play i'm going to slide into that
casual match made action
whether you win or awesome
yeah yeah
yeah isn't it awesome they like cater to
you that you're actually
they let going to
that's a casual destiny schlub over here
who really just you know has
pvp segments where he's got to get some
help we'll have to bring new yeah sort
of ascendant nomad comes back on
um travis is going to lose his mind
because we got to get nomad no matter
trials i'm just gonna like hey i'm just
gonna hang my headphones on the
microphone hit record and then listen
back to it later because this is um you
guys are just gonna give me like a
school session but i just i'm gonna have
to take notes later so i won't i'm very
excited man i'm excited trials is my
favorite
casual game um it's like trials and then
angry birds
oh my god
take this great moment from us but let
me ask you all this real quick serious
question with uh just dance
just dancing just dance of serious work
man come on savage child it is nice
better than trial trials
it's gonna be fun but let me ask you
this though real question
with the fusion i know we talked about
that reads what is it reads regret yes
um did you see the flavor text sir i
thought that was interesting uh
that's the first thing i want to ask you
trust me savathune as osiris
so i can't read to read that little time
but now let me ask you what role y'all
y'all going for because i'm looking at
that final perk you got the headstone
right you got rampage you got firing
line which was always used to be good
and you got vorpal so which one are
going for which which reads head stuff
you go faster now can you educate me
trav why like i i don't mess around with
headstone too much so like why does
everyone go crazy for what is the the
big benefit that people love it so much
uh yeah one second i'm gonna i don't
want to misquote this because i'm really
bad at remembering the verbage for
precision precision final blows spawn a
stasis crystal at the victim's location
why is this so important
well you know what stasis crystal well i
guess it depends what class you're
playing what are warlocks use them for
actually i don't ban that a lot though
for stasis though i do but it's not like
gonna be i know a lot of hunters
probably use it for
the slam you can still do you know
shatter dive
because
like why are you excited for headstone
rolls i'm curious
i think um
go ahead i was just gonna say it's more
like making the crystals that you can
use to shatter therefore to kill other
people i think is the general idea
that's why people like didn't piece
piece bond of the sidearm that was where
people started seeing it first and you
can get that kill with headstone you get
a final blow you spawn a stasis crystal
and then you can shoot that and shatter
it you already weaken anybody around you
depending on the radius i think that's
what they were using it for
um i never got a piece bond with it i
had a decent amount of drops on that one
with my token still never got one with
headstone so i couldn't even tell you
but i know it definitely seemed to
propagate i'm sure a cool guy i know he
did a video on it i need to check it out
um oh cool guys
we gotta get cool guy back he's been on
fire yeah he's been he moved yeah so um
my uh my reason for headstone is that um
i mean
right now i've sort of been in a sliding
mood where i you know if you especially
if you play the stasis subclass to me
that's the main advantage that you get
is the increased mobility on the titan
because the slide is so much better um
and with the added slide you can slide
through crystals and the more crystals
you have the more damage you're doing
all that stuff but honestly that's not
even really the main reason the main
reason is that headstone is a rarer perk
and i already feel like i have a million
guns that have like kill clip and
rampage and outlaw and all that stuff
and i just want to
have a different gun like it's really
comes down to that it's like i don't
have that many guns with headstone so
like that's the one i'm gonna go i think
i might go for
either triple tap vorpal
i think i'm going for triple tap vorpal
or um clown crotch we'll see but what
about you you like what are you going
you going for that the headstone joint
uh i mean i'd like to have one on it so
we'll see but again if i can get one
drop i'll just be happy with that
um
i mean for me depending on if i'm gonna
use it in a pve situation yeah what you
go for i mean vorpal's good for damage
on bosses
um
harmony and adagio are weird i'm still
getting a feel for those like harmony
like actually i was messing around
because i had one with it it's like if
you get a kill with this and you switch
over you get extra damage from it yes
very good with um the kinetic uh shotgun
i'm using right now fractacisus whatever
or whatever it's called yeah
that
yeah you've got that and it hangs for a
little bit so i was like i don't know
how
ester that perk is per se but just in
theory you know kill little guy and then
you want to go put x you know extra
damage into a boss kill a basic enemy
switch and then you know you pop out
more damage already with particle
deconstructor like yeah it's got
potential to add now granted is vorpal
gonna have damage on a boss all the time
yes so is that a good one to go for 100
triple tap as well to save it clown
cartridge wouldn't be a bad backup um
something like that is like quick draw
maybe like hip fire hell no um
triple tap clown cartridge probably
gonna be pretty good
uh accuracy and stability with heating
up
so i mean that's final blows if you're
starting to pop head that's always the
thing about like
certain things like sniper rifles i'm
not gonna pop a lot of heads
for me at least and again in pvp maybe
you do so more power to those but i was
like in pve especially heating up is
kind of useless to me on something like
this because i'm not gonna linear fusion
a lot of little guys i agree to go for
it so
something from yeah triple tap clown
cartridge would be good uh liquid coils
for the higher impact not gonna hurt
anything vorpal harmony would be
interesting headstone would like to see
i'll probably get celerity and quick
draw and just shoot myself in the face
so it's fine you get celerity twice
yeah celery needs to go in the bushes
got it um what did i use it on
which one's that uh after defeating a
target sorry
jinx
uh this fire this weapon fires charges
or draws more slowly and deals increased
damage for a brief time so i've got one
on say like the
ionic dracona like the really slow
fusion rifle but if like i switch over
it's slow but it hits hard
that the i will definitely say after
doing like fusion rifle testing the
other day the high impact like thousand
charge time is a long time by the way
when you charge that thing up it takes a
while to fire but if you can
switch after defeating a target
uh
yeah what fires no that's the one you
got to defeat it with that target so
that one's like you get a kill
and then it fires slower so that one
wouldn't be bad on like a bow
actually because i think i've got that
on the new bow so if you get a kill with
a normal one and then you want to output
more damage on something else you can
stack that one but again you compare
that do you want that or do you want
rampage where you do more damage and
fire the same speed
right so it's weird it's like it's i
don't know i can't but i can't decide
i've messed around but i can't decide
it's interesting you know because i like
i gotta i want to know what the
stats on adagio is as far as is it like
stronger than like a rampage times two
once it's proc it does last long it does
last for a long a couple of seconds and
um harmony i'm starting to love because
once you get vex
bro you throw vex in and you have that
kinetic um shot i was telling you about
it i got one with um the harmony so i
just get a vex kill switch and off the
switch it already is ramped up on in um
in harmony with the extra damage and it
was pretty nice it was pretty nice so i
actually started to get into those
little perks but i got to mess around
with the the one you wanna talk about
head start i haven't really i think i
got the piece i think it was only on the
other piece on sidearm and i didn't get
headstone on it so i haven't been able
to try it yeah i got it on it alright
yeah i don't think i have any guns that
have it i've wanted been wanting to try
it yeah gk bowels in chat was basically
saying if you use it with your fragment
you'll get like stasis energy back so
like it's you know refreshing your
grenades pretty constantly so it's like
more of a synergy thing i think when it
comes to headstone break the crystals
that type of stuff i think it's more
about the synergy of other stuff i'll
get my stasis build going thank you guys
yeah looks pretty cool yeah you of all
people the warlocks are in a good
position seriously
yeah we should be buying it for sure
oh you've had homestone on the
what is that the vel picula the hand
cannon apparently i can roll i just
haven't had it drop yet at all so what
it could roll with someday
i'll get to try it but yeah that is
tomorrow so i mean we actually get to
experience this new version
we're gonna see what this is uh next
week's gonna be very interesting chat um
also next week we have taci on so
between if we get any interesting story
beats we get an exotic and we've got the
trials debate
you can take your fire team chat the
bait and now you can have the encore i
got tassie on my side
he's on the wrong side of history
all these non-pvp mains telling me what
trials should be get out of here
that's all i have to say i love it i
love it it's gonna be fun it's gonna be
fun
but yeah it's like it's kind of a light
week we hashed on so much the last two
weeks we had six hours worth of podcasts
the two previous weeks
so it was like
i was gonna i was honestly gonna say at
this point like we've got trials coming
up cover the seven years the destiny
kind of covered the showcase
i don't honestly have a huge ton of
stuff what do you do you guys have
anything you wanted to discuss
well what trials i did um
we got obviously the the the changing
obviously the rounds from the win rounds
to the uh the challenges which is big
right
you know um
each round is going to start with fresh
special ammo we got that and then there
was a little there was a little tidbit
obviously we got the paid expansion part
oh yeah what's this all right we got the
restricted camera so no three peaking
sword peeking stuff right but then
it says uh restrict a load screen hint
to trials elimination and showdown i was
like what the hell is that
you caught that line
uh
is it talking about like the load-in
screen are they getting rid of it
yeah it was a weird i just wanted maybe
i read it incorrectly where is that
because i'm actually right so crossplay
it was the final third person
camera restricted tool tip and load
screen hint to trials elimination oh
maybe like the load screen says that you
can't that you're restricted in third
person so it actually tells you in game
because not everybody reads the articles
so then it might say
hey
um
third person
things are restricted like sword ammo
you have to have ammo to be third person
and then emotes obviously it might just
flat out say it
right so that might be what it says just
to give you an update because some
people might just jump into trials or
elimination or showdown and not be aware
of the changes i think that might be
a thing though
yeah i kind of missed i didn't catch
that now the thing i got for a trav
obviously was um i saw a fallout tweet
it was in reference to
the cross-play um
requirement it must be enabled right so
the reason why i had it because i did
have um
my experience with uh some pvp this week
you know just getting ready shout out to
my boy hans gretel he's on i don't know
podcast clan but on the pc side so now
we've been playing more so i was jumping
in um
some crossplay matches with him right
and um i will
say the level
was different because now i'm in the pc
pool right so because remember when you
a pc guy plays with an xbox guy i am now
in the pc pool and i noticed i was when
the batches were going i was looking i
was the only one that had xbox logo next
to the steam logo oh yeah you got
dragged into into hell buddy
oh
boy it was spicy it was my i was
fighting for my life so i was fighting
for my life but it was interesting on
that level so i wanted to get your
thoughts obviously with the enabling of
it you know um just clearly gonna affect
anybody who plays with a pc guy stadia
guys they play with console glass
correct yes correct
correct okay all five of you so it'll be
interesting to see what's up but yeah
man just how did you feel about that
track like now that the cross play is
enabled to participate in trials
yeah um i i hope so my reading of that
was that cross play has to be enabled as
in you have to have like set up your
bungie account and all that stuff it
won't let you in if you're still on the
old way of doing things
not that you have to be playing with the
same pool of people who are playing on
pc yeah that was my
reading of it
yeah i hope i'm right because if you
cross play has to be enabled between
everyone then
we're going to have some problems
because i
specifically do not play trials on pc
because of cheaters even though i could
play it with the controller um
so yeah um
i'm uh i think it's fine yeah if if
crossplay has to be enabled i i don't
think i mean it sounds like their old
way of doing matchmaking is basically
dying off like they're
at a certain point you're not going to
be able to not have a bungee name and
all that stuff so this doesn't seem like
it's that big of a but if i'm misreading
it and they're saying that i have to
play with pc players then it's a huge
deal and i hate it no no i was like i
think all they're basically saying is
probably just when you log in for the
first time you got to make your bungee
name they are described cross play is
like console is the big console pool pc
is there if you pair with anyone on pc
you're going to the pc pool you have
left console space i think that's pretty
much it
so mostly
i think it's just going to be as they
kind of describe class cosplay as
working as it is already i don't expect
that to be a huge change
i will be curious though for example if
like cog and i want to play and all of a
sudden he jumps in with me on like pc
it's gonna be like uh sorry in advance
but here we go
yeah it's gonna be look i am i ain't
gonna lie you
my shout out to my boy hans i love you
but i was like i don't know if like for
you you the homie so i will do it for
you right i'm glad i'm not i'm glad i'm
on top here yeah your special case you
know what i'm saying like again say
fourteen seconds
off the planet
i'll go for e i will sacrifice hell and
high water i will deal with everything
to bring back my guy but
all my other clan mates man i i think
i'm gonna have to put y'all on a pve
time to be on pvp time
pve yo strikes nightfalls raids what's
up bro you know what i said what's up
but man it was rough playing glory with
him oh my god i was getting my head
pinched i started to realize different
metas and i was like oh my god um what's
that what's the shotgun the tail the the
the dead man's tail i was getting my
head oh dead man sale yeah
completely different meta there that's
the other thing that that's right
i almost okay
so since my entire clam is on pc i
almost have to have a separate loadout
for when i'm playing with them yes so we
did iron banner last week and i mean we
steamrolled every single team we played
against but like
it it was
i i just i forgot like damn i have to
like reconfigure my brain because i was
doing that before when the platforms
were separate yep anytime i would play i
played a lot of trials on pc
uh and
uh you know i'm
i'm not afraid of playing against pc
players that aren't cheating it's really
just the cheaters that gets me because
uh
but but the metas are different and
playing on controller on pc is also
different than playing controller on
console and so you really have to like
understand which weapons have recoil and
how bad it is on pc versus console and
all that stuff and i just don't want to
have to think about that um i have i
actually haven't tested that out yet so
i have to see if that's yeah i test it
out i did i did a whole bunch of matches
i barely could complete the seven win
card
for the for the glory joy but i got it
done but um yeah different metas the
precise lighting the weapons you know
what which are on pc were a higher meta
like i was getting my head pitch i had
to be very respectful and i actually i
went with a super sweaty build i went
with um ark buddy
to stitch where they was at arc warlock
arc buddy um bottom tree storm crawler
um they kind of let me know where they
were at and that was very helpful
because they just to me they were just
moving like the calculations were faster
bro i was like yo it was it was a level
i was like okay i had to get used to it
so that was the adjustment but other
than that um i'm excited to get back in
man i'm excited to get back in i know
you know chad is a little concerned and
rightfully so we'll see how it plays out
but i am just man i'm pumped i'm pumped
that that the boat and people gonna play
it and e i got you whatever you when you
jump in there you won't get that little
you know a couple of wins you know we'll
get in there just to clarify
i think all the changes they're making
to trials are going to be good except
for matchmaking right so i still think
the experience is going to be
drastically improved to what it was
before especially because cross play is
a thing
i just think matchmaking is going to be
a nightmare yeah and i'm sure you will
agree with me by this time next week
because it's going to be sloppy oh no no
no it's going to be it's going to be lit
because i've been playing with console
people the majority of the time with my
elite controller that has my dynamic
latency input uh i'm very excited right
now so i my spirit is going to be late
oh i didn't worry about you you you out
here scared for no reason it's going to
be late aren't you going to match make
it are you going are you going to happen
i'll do both i want to try it just for
you know for science we got to see right
we got to see what it is and then let's
be honest there's
for me there's always that time where
like my our our team our clan
is predominantly pve right so there's
like a very subset that
is hardcore trials right and that's one
so so to get everybody on at the same
time in my schedule so it is going to be
an advantage to me to say hey nobody's
on i want to still do trials let me see
how this is yeah so it'll be a good you
know social experiment for science
i'll only be doing matchmaking this
weekend
just cc
how's that elitist showing you my
accessibility
i'm doing the reverse accessibility
accessibility
accessibility oh gk bulls arc buddy
getaway artist no yeah that's super pc
that's my anti-pc loadout yes that's my
job you actually stitched me out i
actually run arc buddy getaway artist no
time to explain so it's giving me the
data where they at they're here okay
love it let's go
that's what i got
that's a light show light week we had a
whole lot of nostalgia hit the fields
pretty hard in the beginning playstation
blew it up i've been on an emotional
roller coaster but i mean it is
it is light week no major crazy story
beats happened next week might be busy
we're gonna go back to the shattered
realm
um we're gonna see the first one now we
kind of know what to expect with all our
new abilities it's a lot more
explanation there potentially we got the
exotic quest next week maybe if the
timing's right fourth one the portal i
feel like we've got two so we can break
those rocks right we gotta get it i feel
like that would be right yeah you do the
quest then you can go through the next
three weeks breaking all the rocks and
then my assumption is probably for the
catalyst there's going to be a
collection of either ascended anchors
chests enigmatic chests whatever it is
there's something in each one of those
places behind those walls
that we've got um
now we're gonna have to be able to get
to all of them so i think that's like
some people right now is like why do you
have to get all the anchors why do you
have to do all this other stuff and i'm
like i've got a feeling you're gonna
need to so you may as well just do it
now so
you got a super chat for [ __ ]
shout out to vagabondo with the five
dollar super chat just wanted to say how
this podcast has taken me back to some
of the steams before the last word
wasn't called the last word flat hashtag
flashpoint what was it it's called
flashpoint flashpoint what yeah
that was the yellowjar yeah remember
every week bungie um you got you guys
talked about that old tv show
yeah
yeah man we've been rocking with this
thing a while and i forgot to even
mention like we were talking about uh
history with bungie in seven years like
iron law's podcast wouldn't exist
without destiny
oh yeah literally like literally iron
lord's podcast is based off rise of iron
dlc yeah we literally just jack the name
so to speak right and became iron lords
and then the whole um
just everything you know that led around
that time because it was like that
and game of thrones was going on so the
whole lord stuff and you know saladin it
was it was it was a time you had to be
there
it was one of those destiny is literally
responsible without without that's the
iron podcast does that exist straight up
and uh yeah absolutely all right podcast
doesn't exist and you've been on 1200
guest podcasts that wouldn't happen now
you're in last hand media doing fighting
media probably like literally one game
has changed lives
facts yeah i mean five team chat like
bro like oh man for the first time chat
like like eb
or ds dcp
was like i was so proud of i was like he
got us all a fight jacket when when you
get bronzed and you get illumina what's
up what's the artist what's her name she
does the thing so that was you still
haven't been on it yet carl no i've been
on it i'm surprised i shoot but shout
out i'm not ashamed to say i would love
the opportunity
like that is one thing that he has i'm
like damn i'm so jealous but i'm proud
of my boy but for me my hall of fame
jacket was was yours you don't say
because i was like fighting though like
yo
you are listening
you got a little muted there oh okay can
you hear me can you hear me yeah this is
my his mic is cropping out his high
pitches and he goes when i was getting
hyped
bro like 5t got the call i was like yo
this is so dope so that was my you know
me like the pinnacle podcast that you've
been watching for so long and obviously
dustin and everything you i beat travis
for the first time i'm like oh this
guy's dope it was it was it's cool man
this game has brought so much
opportunities and we've met so many
people but
real quickly your experience i i got to
give you a roses on that one like
the the dcp
no that was
i can't remember i got him on fire team
chat too yeah he used my problem
for that
for that for that set of episodes i got
the host while dustin was out i was like
i'm going to get my buddies on come on
let's get around to get on this show
he's like hey you got anything going on
like in an hour i'm like i'm there
it was short notice or whatever and i
was like fine with me i'll take the spot
so it was you me and tassie right and i
was like well this is like half a crew
i've seen before
it was i was like there were no nerves i
wasn't on there with like you know the i
wasn't on there with destin or anybody
it was just like i was like this is like
the last word just on a different label
so
it was very easy chad i'll get destined
on this show one of these days i just
need to wait for him to stop having an
infant child yeah he's gotta get a
little a little less busy but yeah dcp
was legit because
i mean yeah the other piece is like ash
does her art and the way she did the
cheetah for me and that was like my face
reveal because i actually hadn't done my
face at that point on camera
there was like a couple people who had
probably seen me do it on one stream
probably literally a year and a half
before that happened like almost in
early i was like oh should i should i
not and then i was like i just won't i
didn't do it in the youtube videos but
there was probably like one random
stream out there with it but most people
had never seen it and then she was like
here's the cheetah armor here's the face
and then like i start the podcast and
then i like talk to me for a little bit
and then i turn it on
uh it was yeah dcp was and that's again
like those are people from planet
destiny now dcp live watching them
forever
so i mean that was really cool they're a
ton of fun too and it's just always
how many how many how many podcasts are
about one game
bro i've been watching them for so long
bro when they from the playing destiny
like i remember holtzman was a big
influence on me like i i would live for
his like weapon reviews
obviously caccus has been think about i
just think about like all the content
creators i follow and then got a chance
to meet and then i think about all the
people that we've had on last word who
you've introduced me to that i didn't
even really know about how awesome they
are you know what i mean like we've had
i mean we had bunch of it too right
let's be honest we had uh you know
composer homie yeah shout out to the
homie skye skye thank you
everybody i was like sitting at gcx i
was talking to nine hydras for a while
picking picking her brain for a while
talking to i think his name's danny like
just i mean i could sit there and talk
to those guys i met blake i met
uh
dj
i
got to shake deeja's hand that was
that was uh yeah but it's like i met
blake at the bar i'm trying to think who
else i met one's not there anymore
bailey's like man gcx i cannot wait
pinot pinot pinot oh adam hell yeah
yeah
yeah dude yeah follow him on twitter if
you want puns dude his are fantastic
hilarious remember he was asking us
about a a gambit and whatever
which one should go yeah kind of hinted
it was gonna go yeah one of them which
one yeah that was dope yep that was
though mesa had like so many people man
and we got a jar if we had job but
listen the community is amazing like cb
every oh red queen the list goes on so
many dope people in this community
that's just been awesome and because of
this damn game yeah
there's there's artists who have careers
they're they're monkeys just careers
have been paid like it's life mileage
damn yeah we done did it man firing
range now with all of those it's just
the beginning
because they got fallout cool guy
drewski
uh candycakes and why am i for getting
one
oh merc mercury's had him on here
yay mark
spreadsheet master
and you had old crucible radio with like
bones and stuff long time ago
no there's it's
yeah i mean yeah i'd have to go back
through the list because i know i'm
missing way too many our four hour show
with uh ob katie cat obi katie catch
right there that means yeah yeah yeah a
lot of people a lot super excited we got
to get sent to know my back for track
just so i could see them geek out on
baby oh yeah they're going to go
i'm just going to have to like record it
and just kind of like listen take notes
i'll be over here with my notepad
writing
so i can take all these notes and then i
can just have so much slander come my
direction
i got a question for trav i never asked
him this what was the
first time you kind of came across us
and heard us i'm very curious like how
that because i know we got teddy as a
late that's one of our links but i'm
just curious like when did you come
across us
yeah because we ought to tell you teddy
before i knew you guys but i've never
met teddy in person teddy and i have
just been in each other's orbit and not
seeing each other um
i i honestly think cog i think i just
met you on fire team chat so i'm kind of
weird especially for a destiny guy i i
don't watch any shows i don't watch
youtube i don't i don't watch any twitch
streamers so like i make content that i
would never consume like i would never
watch a show i fireteam chat is the one
show i watched but only because i worked
with all those guys and i knew them so
it was like i was hanging out with
friends like i listened to some of idn
shows but
um yeah i i think i just met you on fire
team chat and that was our first time
that was the first time i was like
yeah i think i think it was the first
time i'd heard of heard of you at all um
and i would just remember my takeaway
from that was that you had a really good
laugh and you were funny to hang out
with and that's something you're always
looking for when you do podcasts and
stuff is because like
some people are just not that
interesting and that's always that's
never a good a good time you know i've
i've talked to just
people who just don't have a lot to say
and it's it's never good so i i was like
oh he's on my mind and then i think uh i
think you or e reached out to me and had
me on the show and it was the first time
oh bro
they were like bring him
back remember e they was like we love
what travis is on yeah bring him back
and then he can't be very surprised to
hear that considering that i think the
first 20 minutes i was talking about
star wars i was telling you guys the
mcclunky origins i think that was our
yeah
we had to get the segment we had to get
the mcclunky though i mean that you
literally say it every time you're on
fire team chat i'm like all right now we
gotta know
i immediately insulted uh um e by
telling him that he looked like in
dallas
yeah i was just like i was like they're
never gonna have me back talk about star
wars for 20 minutes
yeah that was just i was like yeah
they're never gonna have me back but
yeah works out i like hanging out with
you guys obviously i give you guys like
three hours of my time every week so i
appreciate you brother yeah you fit in
you fit in and it it's cool to see us
grow and sky's the limit we still got
more things to do i still love doing
this and uh yeah man i'm excited destiny
witch queen peak stuff coming we're
gonna have more
talks debates fat one of the funnest
motorcycle he was i always liked where
we have our fights
and i get into it yeah i was like the
big one yeah when it was
i mean i don't think i've been here for
one of those i really want to see the
last big one was sun setting so that was
the biggest one we've had probably
really mad at each other and he hated me
because i joked about it the week before
luke smith
dropped the bomb that it was coming the
week before on the podcast i was like
you know because like you know
sunsetting rolling stuff out like
getting rid of some things he's like oh
that's a horrible idea bam he's like can
you not talk to luke smith please for
the love of god don't get rid of my
stuff he was so mad it was it was like
yo tribe it felt like everything i think
it was a good idea no i'm i'm i'm over
it now but i'm saying every it was just
funny looking back at it in retrospect
because of how opposed i was and it felt
like every suggestion he made the
following twap it would be in there and
i'm like i can't stand him right now
they're listening to his foolishness and
it's driving me crazy so it was just
this funny knock down drag out and like
those are the moments man
says remember picky food i'm like that's
daily for me that hasn't changed will we
roast it
condiments
yeah i need to roast them on that more
that's
uh unfathomable to me but mm-hmm
hilarious can't wait can't wait man e3
please cancel i would like to go to gcx
yeah you guys are going to be like all
right let's watch him order his burger
because i want to just
i want to go back to the leviathan hotel
havoc the thing is massive yeah i play
bro was massive yeah frozen chicken
cream hotel it is
like you've got all the rooms you've got
like six restaurants still indoors pool
connected outside still keep walking
connects to giant convention hall and
it's all
indoors and connected which is
pretty much the only way to do that for
tampa because it's sweaty as hell but i
was just like
yep yeah that was their video where we
did it live with the bad lighting on
their own and like the porch of the
patio yeah
yeah all trees in the back it was sad
audio about sound yeah that's pretty
terrible
it was it was our first though it was it
was hot
love at first sight man we got it
another another podcast and trav i'm
ready it's gonna be late this is my
twitter episode of the show it feels the
friend game got the just a just a a
rom-com with a third guy just watching
it happen
this episode is called the last word the
third wheel
[Laughter]
on that note we are right at about two
hours and
we have definitely been in our fields
back probably about as much as we need
to be so
at this point uh we can work on wrapping
this thing up travis you got anything
you can talk about or anything you're
working on
i know you just dropped some stuff for
uh world war z but yeah
yeah yeah uh i did just drop some stuff
but i'm already working on my next
review uh i am reviewing a game called i
am fish it is from the makers of i am
bread this time instead of bread that
you are you are a fish instead
it is
an insane
the game made by insane people and i'm
really enjoying it so far
um
and yeah other than that you can find me
on twitter i do a show on sunday
mornings called bitcast now with aims
and some old guy whose name i forgot um
i'm just kidding his name's dan i just
hate him and uh
yeah
and uh to you e i would just like to say
congratulations on stepping into the
next part of your life and uh never
forget
the
uh
age the time proven words of the
stranger
all ends or beginnings
deep fair enough some depth okay
remember that
ending credit
last cut scene of vanilla d1 campaign
vanilla d1
man
way back in the fields there this is the
nostalgia episode so i guess it makes
sense it really is
what about you cog we got uh how many
podcasts do i need to find you in in the
next week that are gonna bid well i
guess it would depend on if you were
subscribed to last stand media's patreon
how many more you'd have
but overall how many do i get to watch
you on this week
uh
four
so yeah we got obviously uh definitely
duke that just went live we recorded
yesterday it should be up now where mr
maddie plays amazing content creators
some fun we talked about actually
finally got a chance to meet him in real
life obviously based on the uh last day
of media event that we just did which
was awesome
um yeah good show check that out if you
want what's going on the latest in xbox
and stuff like that and then um i got a
chance to uh cast with the mayor the
mayor of butler pa uh my man ben smith
we did a great uh 12 minute spoiler cast
would be interesting very polarizing
game
so very i gotta check that out at some
point yeah very interesting and it the
the creativity of the game is
interesting and what you discover is
very controversial so check that out
that's defining do ultimate and then
obviously iop returns this sunday
fresh new time 11 a.m eastern i'll get
it in before the football the lords bend
the knee to the 49ers and the rest of
the nfl oh is that really the reason
that's oh yeah there it is
the time for football yeah
yeah cognito and i are also from nowhere
near each other and both 49er fans and
not even remotely near that state i was
like oh he's a 40. yeah we're both 49er
fans which is you guys are both 49er
fans yes
so am i yeah i live here
let's go i'm about to buy a three-person
emote from a bungie of course i'm a
49ers
that's ridiculous but i mean you grew up
what you grew up towards like la though
right
no oh i was born in oakland i grew up in
the bay area oh well okay you could have
been a raiders fan
i went to raiders games as a kid but i
was like nah i i always associated more
with uh
san francisco
that's hilarious nice yeah big time i
went to uh i've been to candlestick
before as well dominican okay before
before
it doesn't exist anymore yeah yeah i was
before that i was there
yeah man well we'll talk 49 stories for
sure but um yeah that's dope that's even
a better one oh see it was meant to be
i know we're about to wrap up the
podcast but now i have to know how you
guys are 49ers fans like
i moved all over the place but when i
kind of came of the age of under being
aware of like getting into football i
lived in sacramento
so
i lived in the sacrament there's no team
there so closest one to me and it was
literally during jerry rice joe montana
steve young it was that trio going on
when i got into football i'm like yeah
well of course and then i moved to texas
and literally like the cowboys always
met the 49ers the amazing championship
championship so if you're a 49ers saying
at all you can't be a cowboys fan
typically because those are going to go
against each other so i moved here and i
was like screwed i'm staying at 49ers
fan and i stuck all the way through
living in nice yeah like 4th through
12th grade in dallas and nope still not
going to be a cowboys fan so yeah i've
been as long as i know
yeah similar exam yeah mines was
different it was that
in sports the only new york team my
first team of all was the mets right if
you're a mets fan in baseball they just
like the bad news bear they're just the
most
they'll lose in the most embarrassing
heart crushing ways known to man right
oh i know so yeah as a met fan i
remember it now getting into football
i'm like wow i'm you know kind of like
i'm learning the game i'm getting older
and i'm starting to learn and i was like
oh what's this team with the red and
gold uniforms they look cool right and i
just started watching them and to
mentally in myself it must have been
something subconscious like i'm never
doing a new york team again after the
pain the mets put me through right so
i'm never going to be a giants fan and
actually i definitely can't be a giant
fan because i remember i was like who's
this joe montana everyone's all crazy
about
and then i watched um giants versus uh
niners in a playoff game and lawrence
taylor knocked out joe montana in the
game and they won i was hurt i was like
oh no they knocked out the guy that i
came to see i don't like
so i didn't like the giants the jets are
just to be the bets is in in football
so i was just like i cannot be i've
already got the mets i don't need your
your you know evil this karma and that
was that and then um yeah so
surprisingly even though i'm a niners
fan most people assume i'm like hardcore
joel i'm actually a steve young fan
because when i started watching and
becoming knowledgeable steve young took
over i'm like why does everybody hate
him this guy is amazing like left-handed
could scramble i was like this guy's
like amazing i mean like i get it so i
was the niner fan that defended steve
young we never won he'll never be joe
montana so 94 will forever be the
magical year for me because the guy that
had the monkey on his back that no one
said could ever compare one wins that
super bowl
i followed that team all the way through
from the very beginning so yeah yeah and
i stayed loyal i just was like i'm not
even during the bad years the alex smith
years all the terrible coaches
singletary
all
in the past decade yeah but before like
there was 20 years of like kind of
garbage for me yeah of pay yeah yeah
yeah yeah paid so i still lost you guys
for sticking around i don't really have
a choice so
i got to go to the new one though i got
it i haven't been to it's in santa clara
yeah i got it you guys come stay here
we'll go together we'll have to yeah
we'll have to figure out a uh see if
there's a fast 10 49ers football game
co-weekend crazy fast all that together
in one and then we'll be like all right
that's enough nerding out
yup facts but yeah i got to do it i've
actually never been to an nfl game
though
yeah oh wow oh it's cool it's i was like
yeah yeah it makes other sports look
really like well except for hockey but
it makes other sports look mild
yeah followed obsessed
basketball for me
yeah well i went to ku that's true and
for jayhawks like
it started there so it's like in allen
field house like that was kind of a
magical experience but yeah never been
to an nfl game i wanted to go when the
cowboys played the 49ers here but that
was like it was going to be 250 for
nosebleed corner seats i'm like it's
still better at home and i don't care as
much about the cowboys but yeah if i go
to santa clara that that'll be yeah we
got we got to plan something at least if
we do the san fran trip we'll try to
plan it around the game and visit travis
at the same time yeah and ign officers
that'd be doing yeah they'll make a
whole thing of it right yeah we gotta
wait till coven's all done because yeah
exactly do you monetize sorry about that
guys
now you're good but look yeah sunday at
11 a.m i went on for the crazy tangent
new reds laughing yeah so 11 a.m because
of football and all that good stuff and
uh of course the last word man we back
thursdays i love the time i guess it
allows me to do a lot of other things
and i love the fact that we get to twab
right on time and it's exciting and it's
new and the thoughts are fresh but eek
what do you got going on sir i had to
bring up one more when it came to
arguments because i saw it in chat and i
forgot about it the hawkmoon argument oh
man we went in on that one so hard
yo you even had forte against me he came
through i know we had a forte on the
podcast for that one i'm pretty sure so
no the hawkmoon argument was hilarious
too fierce i remember that yeah i forgot
goodwood good yeah those are both photos
over there we have some photos yeah we
love them
um for me
i don't have to wake up at 4 30 in the
morning anymore
so my world's gonna be a little
different you guys will see more content
more streams
basically i'm gonna be online a lot so
you guys will find me a lot um
as you guys know shout out to advanced
gg keeping me running not all weird
hours of the day of course
um
[Music]
one day i'm gonna get a shaker in
travis's hand not yet but one day i've
got a plan i've got a plan for that one
so i'll let you guys know when that one
comes through um but for now yeah it's
like i
i'm i'm this full-time for the moment so
if you guys
want to support me you want to find me
you guys know where to do that any and
all ways possible um but for me yeah
i'll be
i'll be busy and trying to figure out
the rest of this stuff going on uh but
for this week this has been a hell of a
fun episode
um cog and i definitely took this one
over a little bit travis just got to
have his ears feel filled with nostalgia
and history of the podcast and you know
osiris and saint 14 got to
think about the days of the days past
yes
that's right
well chat you guys have been fantastic
thank you guys so very much all of you
guys showing up on youtube it's slowly
seeing more and more you guys trickle in
so thank you guys uh but for this
episode 165 next week we have tassie on
should be a fun one if we get an exotic
quest and everything else who knows the
trials review
stay tuned for travis he's gonna have
his notes i guarantee he's gonna have
some thoughts
um
you guys have been fantastic so thank
you guys making this an awesome into my
weird weird emotional rollercoaster of a
day
but for these two gentlemen please
follow them find them support them just
go hit refresh on the world war z
um aftermath ign site give him like six
million views on that one page spam uh
please go support last and media they're
doing good things over there i can't get
through the philip interview by the way
yeah bro it's coughing i got about 25
minutes in and i'm like i gotta listen
to something else i'm going to lose it
so yeah listen to the whole thing and
the whole time i was just
uh
that is a hell of an interview but again
go defining dude go support this man out
there so you guys are all amazing we
love you thank you and for this episode
it has been
the last
you guys are amazing have a good one